for every challenge that exists prepare
yourself for it don't go into it
unprepared the man or woman who's
unprepared for a challenge will probably
not come out of it the way he or she
wants to come out of it but you have a
better chance if you are prepared for it
which is why I wouldn't got a PhD why
because I felt like talent wise you were
prepared to be one of the greatest
speakers in this generation but
language-wise you're not prepared to be
one of the greatest speakers
diversity-wide you are not prepared you
grew up in Detroit which is probably the
most segregated City United States of
America you're not prepared to be
diverse because you've not been in an
environment that was at Birth you need
to prepare yourself for where you want
to be so for my children you will run
into some of the greatest humans in life
prepare yourself to get the most out of
that relationship I was just with
somebody reaching they was like yo I
love you more in person than I did on
the videos that's not by accident and so
to my children prepared for everything
it doesn't mean that you're going to win
because you're prepared but you have a
better chance of winning if you are
prepared they got mad at me when they
were were younger they might have gone
to 50 50 School in terms of diversity
when they got older they were the
minority why are we in the high school
we're in the north because you're going
to Michigan State so we're not going to
prepare you when you get there we're
going to prepare you not so now they're
like okay Dad when they travel the world
we are prepared why because we went to
school with and so I say racism economic
struggles marriage parenting prepare
yourself in advance for these situations
so that when they come you have a better
chance of controlling those situations
and not letting those situations control
you need motivation top 10 We Believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I quit in my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find the motivation to keep going
and if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Eric
Thomas and my take on his top 10 rules
of success
enjoy
rule number two invest in your dream
well for with something for others you
know we kind of live you know from check
to check you know
um wealth didn't belong to us like you
know we could have money to survive you
know and maybe somewhat strive but not
to thrive you know and so I was taught
hey you live from check to check you get
a job you rely on somebody else you give
them your best 30 40 years you know you
you're with your kids when you can be
you know whenever they need you there
you're there and your priority is work
work work work
um so it was a I had a working class
mentality you know when I was growing up
I definitely didn't have a wealth
mentality I'd I teeter-tot with poverty
mentality my mom would get mad at me but
for sure a worker's mentality explain
that just meaning that you know
we are supposed to work for somebody
we're supposed to take our gifts and our
time and our talent and use it to make
somebody else's dreams become a reality
you know
um we don't invest in our own dreams or
our own goals you know
um we we we can't do things that cause
us to take risks we got to stay in the
safety zone you know we've got to do
things that are uncomfortable so a job
you know a nine to five Insurance
whatever you know and it's so funny it's
always enough to survive but it's never
enough to thrive you know that was the
concept you got enough
to survive but we never had enough you
know to put us in a position where we
could go away for a month or you could
go to all your kids events you know and
it was just funny it was like I know
when I was working at Michigan State it
was like wow my boss gets to come and go
as she pleases
I don't get to go to my daughter's
events when she gets an award an
academic award at school because I have
to be at work even though no child no no
college student is coming to my office
at eight o'clock in the morning but I
have to be there because but my boss
gets to come and go you know as she
wants and so you know I just realized
she should get to come and go and she
wants like she should have that luxury
but I should have it as well I shouldn't
have another human telling me that I
can't go and enjoy my daughter and
create these memories with my child rule
number three find your purpose I would
just say one
sometimes
it's so close to you that it's hard to
you know figure out especially when
you're comparing yourself you know to
other people I would say start with the
people that's in your inner circle okay
like they would know they're around you
all the time they wouldn't know what you
do
yeah they're around you all the time
they could say to you man I think you do
this well I think you do that well and
then I think whatever they say like
believe it yeah like so if you don't
know they're going to know and if they
know like literally trust them you know
the other thing I would say is
you know look at the things that you you
naturally love and are attracted to like
I remember being younger and I was
attracted to now that I look back to
Martin Luther King you know like how
kids talk about you know Michael Jordan
I don't know that I ever watched Michael
Jordan and go I could be like that like
I don't know if I watched him it was
like yo let me go get a basketball and
try to but when I would listen to
Malcolm X speak I would like No Mess oh
like Coretta or Rosa Parks I would be
like I could do that like I could like
even though I never said anything to
anybody and I never even practiced it in
my heart or heart I was attracted to it
I was moved by and I think when we are
attracted to things or move by things it
is an indicator that that's probably
what we could be good at rule number
four break up with your excuses I've
been to third world countries where it
does not matter how early you wake up it
does not matter how long you stay up it
doesn't matter what your skill sets are
it doesn't matter
you don't have opportunity you have
people all over the world who are dying
to get here literally dying to get here
you have an opportunity of a lifetime
and where much is given much is required
so if you have an opportunity to be
wealthy to build phenomenal
relationships to start a business like
you can just you got LLC non-profit you
know what I'm saying uh S Corp like you
got opportunities you got banks that you
can get loans from uh you can go online
and sell stuff from online like you
don't have to have a store anymore
you're a storefront like you can
literally become rich from your watch so
it's like yo instead of you looking at
everything that's not look at what is so
absolutely is there some stuff to
complain about one thousand percent it's
a whole bunch of stuff I can complain
about it's a lot of stuff that I can be
angry about but
man my grandmother died at 93 and a
month later my other grandmother died at
90. I didn't realize how quick life was
I'm like yo my grandmother was 93 I
spent 51 years with both of them they're
gone it's over I will never be able to
talk to my grandmother again and I'm
next so because life is short I don't
have time to focus on what's not I've
got to focus on what is then get up and
go get it and and for me it's like guys
some of you in this room have
opportunities that I don't have some of
you in this room have connections or
network I don't have
and and I'm killing the game and you're
not so I need you to I need you to
understand where you are
America's not perfect I don't know if
there's a place on planet Earth that is
so we're not looking for perfect but we
are looking for opportunity and we have
it so it's like yo say it because I need
you to understand what you have and then
I need you to appreciate what you have
and then I need you to go after
everything that's got your name on it
with no excuses because some man when I
pulled up and I saw you know the scholar
I was like yo do you know there were
people 400 years ago 300 years ago who
were in the process of building this and
it was a vision and they never got to
experience it
I know you know you know do you know
what type of mindset you have to have to
build something that you know that
you're not going to get to enjoy but yet
you put energy into it because you're
thinking about the Next Generation
you've got this Vision that's going to
outlast you like that's that's that's
rare and so now it's been built go fly
first class it's been built go live on
the people asking why you live on the
east coast and then you live on the west
coast because it's too cold that's why
and if I can get a house in the Gold
Coast I'm going there so it's like yo we
have opportunity whatever you do don't
waste it don't cry about it get up and
go make it happen also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your more
specific plan of action to make sure
you're getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five eliminate cancel
culture I don't
and I'm not saying I don't subscribe to
cancel but I think cancel is
um you know that's a culture where you
know people are building you up and they
have the power to you know destroy
gotcha you understand what I'm saying
about it you know it's just a
perspective yeah I'm not against you
know like up you can't whatever two
cancel but I've I've built my church
I've poured into people since 2006 2007.
these are people who have helped get
through divorce people who have helped
not to get a divorce people to get
through cancer help their kids go to
college you know people not trying
people not canceling people that's
Entertainment to me you know what I'm
saying like you can get canceled if you
own entertainment I'm not an Entertainer
you know I'm a pastor you know I'm a I'm
a coach you know I'm an activist you
know um you know nobody's trying to the
people who I have built up they're not
about to go oh he said I'm through with
him yeah it's like yo that's our pastor
that's our brother that's our friend and
I think when you're dealing with people
you're have a relationship with it's
different than people you don't have you
know people who are just you know
entertainment that's different you don't
have a bond with that person but if you
are if you have a a family that's what I
have on the internet I have a family
these are people that I help Elevate so
even if I mess up all they're looking
for is yo I messed up I'm I'm human I'm
not God I'm gonna make mistakes and
they're like yo we're gonna forgive you
so I just think that to me that's more
entertainment like I don't have a um I
don't have a sponsor you know but you
got to worry about yeah we have a
sponsor and all that like I'm not uh if
I get kicked off of YouTube you know I
think they're probably more people
showing my stuff on their sites that I'm
probably showing online if that makes
sense they're playing my message when
they working out doing whatever so you
know again yeah yeah yeah that is for
even my books we self-published yeah you
know what I'm saying you know so now I
do have a publisher now but I I just
think I'm in a different Arena and and
even with um some people who I heard
Snoop say something I thought was funny
Snoop was like I wish they would try
that but you're talking about Snoop
who's been around since yeah you know
later 80s 90s you know so he's built a
base I think it's for people who again
entertainment has built them you know
the culture has built them and because
the culture has built them they feel
like they have the right to tear them
down but I've been around since 2006 man
doing God's will sure you're gonna have
to get in the Holy Ghost phase
and the Bible says
um you know who the who who the Lord
sets free is free indeed and even when
you look at David David said I won't
touch Saul even though he's trying to
take my life because God says touch not
my anointing you know so I feel like you
know I'm God's anointed so it's Saul
didn't want him to begin yeah yeah and
David was like Hey I could take your
life but there's a higher calling and
God said touch not and so I just feel
like when you're anointed even if people
form weapons against you they're not
going to prosper rule number six seek
motivation you have to let your pride go
and you have to acknowledge that it
hurts to lose okay you know and I think
a lot of people who are like me grew up
you know your father's not in your life
you're homeless
you lose it you know and it's like
people are so prideful
that they only want even if you look at
social media and I don't think it's a
thing wrong with I just wish that they
would be more balanced it's like people
only want to show when they're winning
yeah you know and and winning has its
advantages but losing has its advantages
as well I don't think if Mike Michael
Jordan wouldn't have lost to Boston or
lost to Detroit like what if he would
have come out as freshman year and won
he probably would have you know settled
but the fact that he got beat down seven
years in a row it's like you look at
LeBron it's like aren't you supposed to
be retiring sometime soon like how are
you supposed to be how you retiring but
you look better than kids who are coming
into your twins why because he's hungry
it's like they're still not giving me my
credit like they still don't acknowledge
me as the goat but some of us are so
prideful you know we don't want to say
you know it hurts that my biological
father's not in my life like we go man
I'm not tripping on my man in my life
might care about my man like I'm good no
you're not yes your father the person
that's supposed to bring you in this
world and it's supposed to be a model to
God our Father which are in heaven like
yet you struggling just say it yeah it's
okay because when you acknowledge that
you're hurt you are acknowledging that I
got something I need to work on over
here there's some things I need to
whatever so for me it's like I became
very okay with you losing yes you lose
an e and this is going to be second
generation to lose the third generation
look like no you got to stop the losing
so so that's what happened so now that
I'm successful I look at it as I can't
take my foot off the brakes because if
you got and again no disrespect to my
father you know what I'm saying I never
want him to think I'm dogging him out
you know but he wasn't in my life so
stuff that happened yeah so whatever
happened a generation before him his
generation I'm trying to break that a
cycle I know that the Next Generation
they're just not going to pick up my
cycle easily you feel me like it don't
work like that it's not like Psycho
Cycle you broke it and it's just broken
forever no it could be cycle cycle you
broke it next cycle pick up on that
cycle so I'm always like e you gotta you
gotta choke it out like you know you see
those movies where they're getting
chased by you know the villain or
whatever and they might knock him down
bust him in the head and run and then
the village back right up Michael Myers
yeah cut his head off you know you got
like like and I think that's why David
killed Goliath in the in the matter that
he did he just didn't beat him but he
cut his head off to let it be known like
yo this is over it's done like we're not
we're not dealing with this no more the
people who don't want to acknowledge
that they're struggling like yo that
could be a trap yes like maybe you're
not struggling in some areas but there
are other areas that I always say I'm
blessed financially but people be like I
wish I had the money you had okay maybe
you do I don't know but let me tell you
this
my my money did buy us a house in
California but it can't buy us a home
like money can't have me and DD Blissful
no you know what I'm saying yes money we
have great insurance but it couldn't
stop Diddy from getting a mess now can
she will she have good health care yes
absolutely but can it stop her from
getting the disease it cannot you know
can I buy a car yes I can but but that
car doesn't money can't buy me Safety
and Security on the road yes you know
what I'm saying and so it's like yo
don't trip money has its place
absolutely and go get as much of it as
you can yes but don't think that this is
going to solve this and so for me it's
like yo here's some stuff you gotta your
family has left you to deal with
that they didn't bless you with now you
got to get it and now you got to give it
to Jalen and Jada and you have to know
that it's not going to come easy to them
that hunger doesn't come from what
you've accomplished that hunger comes
from what you still are seeking to
accomplish so if you feel like you've
accomplished everything then you're not
going to be hungry rule number seven
don't let adversity stop you it's not
the adversity itself that's killing you
because it's not like it's new and
you've not ever experienced adversity
but but what's happening is because you
are almost worshiping a great day a day
without any trials or tribulations a day
where you you know indeedy it ain't
gonna be no disagreement you and the
kids you you know you uh in the church
you in the and so when stuff start
happening it's like it throws me off
like and God's like stop adversity is
guaranteed you know it's coming you know
you're gonna see it you're gonna
experience it stop stop it but but the
choices you make as a result of it
that's different so there's someone you
you're making a choice not to speak to
your spouse for two or three days come
on I'm talking to somebody we are
dealing with relationships you know hi
so we can keep it 100. you feel me like
after the sermon I'm talking about after
the sermon like we're not talking about
how you feel in church we talk about how
you feel at home when y'all beefing
listen to me adversity is guaranteed
y'all y'all not gonna see everything
alike it's going to be some conflict
because there are differences in opinion
which is a black Sin you know I was
telling somebody the other day we had a
uh we had an interview somebody
interviewed DD and I for a project they
were doing uh in their master's program
and um I was saying you know it's a
beautiful thing for my children I was
telling the person that DD is has one a
set of skills and I have a different set
of skills so now my kids gonna get all
the skills are you this is are you
listening what I'm saying is making
sense so like if me and DD both had the
same skills and that would mean guess
what that the kids would get all of our
great skills but they would be missing
some other stuff why because DD and I
don't you feel me but because DD and I
are not the same because DD is more a a
structure more uh systematic amen more
stable the kid's gonna get some of that
but because Dad amen is a risk taker is
an innovator you feel what I'm saying
they gonna get some of that and so I
need y'all to stop I need you to
understand adversity gonna come in your
house somebody might end up getting sick
are you hearing what I'm saying like
adversity is gonna strike but the
question is not is adversity gonna
strike the question is what choices are
you gonna make on adversity strikes are
you going to choose to still get along
are you going to choose to love your
differences are you going to choose to
be able to communicate in a way where
y'all y'all not getting it make like
turn it into a like a storm come on are
you not go stop are you gonna stop
talking to people and cut people off
because they don't act the way you want
them to act and do what you are you hear
what I'm saying like are you gonna just
cut people off because they don't meet
your are you for it like if we were
going why be Christians if we gonna live
like people people who don't know Christ
yeah Am I by myself why why what what
sense does it make to call ourselves
Believers in the most high if we're
going to treat people like people treat
people when they don't know the most
high when when when when they when they
don't when they're atheists and they
don't believe that there's a God when
they don't believe God exists like when
they don't read the word when they don't
have all this beautiful instruction
through the world like we we acting just
like them
what's the purpose and so praise God
this morning adversity is going to
strike it don't let it make you a a evil
person adversity is going to strike
don't let it make you bitter adversity
is going to strike don't make it don't
make it make God feel like he you forgot
what the word said amen math fact let's
just stop can we put some Jeremiah 29 11
on it amen why am I saying that because
adversity shouldn't change his plans for
you
I'm just being real adversity shouldn't
change God's plans for you what's that
what's happened on the outside shouldn't
change what happens on the inside what
the devil doing had nothing to do
with what God doing a couple of somebody
am I talking to myself what the devil is
doing should have absolutely nothing to
do what God is doing for you absolutely
nothing the plans that God has for you
amen those plans should be put in motion
you should receive those plans you
should embrace those plans and you
should lay those plans out rule number
eight X
execute
execute on the things that they say they
wanted to get done not what you want me
to get done my mother wants me to get
done my coach wants me but the things
that I really feel like if I do these
things I'm going to be successful
execute on the things that you said you
were going to execute on so then why
don't most people ever find success like
if it really is and I know what's hiding
in the word execute but most people do
not and I always tell people only
execution matters yeah that's it but how
do people get good at that so the first
thing you got to do is you got to get
out of your feelings like for me
these are great people who can blow up
like who could be successful whatever
they touch but something happened that
day you know you woke up got into it
with your spouse or your kids call with
something that was going on or you were
sick like they're a group of people that
feel like it's okay not to execute
because I'm not feeling okay because
today is not a good day because all the
stars didn't line up and at the end of
the day none of that matter like to have
a good day is great but just because you
have a good day you still gotta execute
and so I think for most people they go
wrong because they think it's a feeling
when execution is a fact
one of my favorite quotes from you is
about that that feelings basically
aren't facts and facts are the things
that are going to help you process
through your feelings that's a
paraphrase but it's pretty close
um and I got that actually from the book
uou which is absolutely phenomenal thank
you uh and what I love about it is this
idea of you need to take responsibility
for you that there are going to be
difficult times in your life there are
going to be times where you have every
reason to make an excuse absolutely but
that won't serve you and I'm always
telling people the most Insidious thing
about excuses is that they're valid yeah
like most people have a real reason to
say like hey this didn't happen for me
whatever in fact tell us about Inky
which was it's a really powerful story
I've heard you tell before yeah so you
know first of all for me the whole icky
you know
I don't want to call it a disability I
don't want icky to call me you know I'm
saying but for one not to have the use
of their arm training every day for the
NFL going hard I think he was trying to
get out of some pretty dire
circumstances absolutely uh multiple
cousins living with them uh they're
shifting out the bed right so one person
sleep in the bed one day another person
sleep in the bed and for Inky to lose
everything but say to his self like yo
this doesn't matter what matters is the
success that I want what I promised my
grandmother when I promised my mother
what I promised my wife what I promised
myself and so Inky's thing was yo
despite this happening I owe it to
myself to still be the person that I
dreamed of being in this setback will
only be a setup for a comeback rule
number nine rise to Excellence
Excellence can I be honest with you and
I don't even know if I should be saying
this on camera
but whatever the stuff is because I
operate at such a high level nobody even
I've never been asked
whatever the I you know if I'm mandating
I mean back then I back then if I'm
wearing the math man I I just do what I
think is right but nobody ever is like
hey they like yo you number one we need
you in the school we need you in the
prison we need you in the and so I take
precautions but I'm saying at the same
time I operate at such a high level
Jackie Robinson got to be the first
African-American because he operated as
a highest level Martin Luther King got
to sit down and create legislation for
people of color women why because he was
the best so I'm just saying when you
when you operate at a spirit of
Excellence
you rise above some of the minutia like
you don't Michael Jordan let's like you
got calls he was MJ I know he pushed my
man on the left you know what I'm saying
that last play against Utah
we know it was a five but it's MJ you
know what I'm saying you can't call the
file with MJ making his shot winning the
championship you can't call the five and
I'm an MJ fan you saw a little a little
baby love you know move to the side you
know
when you operate in a spirit of
Excellence you get calls you know
there's certain things that you know
you're able to accomplish and you're
able to do so I would just say when
you're average you know people do give
you a hard time but when you're
excellent and people know you're
excellent they want to be associated
with excellence and so if you're
excellent I always say planes fly above
the cloud so it doesn't matter if it's
snowing if it's raining as long as it's
not thunder in life they go above the
clouds they're not dealing with rain and
snow they they go above that and they
you know and so when you're excellent
you go above some of the you know
whatever so man I've been I've been my
wife and I have been safe my daughter I
think my son got it he's jiondo he was
24 of 25 maybe at the time and just
walked straight through it but um me and
my wife have been phenomenal haven't had
any issues travel just like today you
know we keep our distance but at the
same time take pictures engage and I've
been you know I've been blessed you know
so again when you excellent yeah I just
feel like when you're excellent the
world treats you a little different
Beyonce show up somewhere they're gonna
is she gonna get a little different
treatment than uh fiance see what I said
I don't know who she is but Beyonce just
gonna get a different treatment because
she operates at a high level at rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is live in the
moment you know I had to ask myself the
other day
you know what's happening now um
what's happening now he you know because
I did I got caught up with the um
I won't use the word fear I'll use the
word
cautious okay you know with DD having Ms
yes and this whole covet thing because
we don't know how you know it's
spreading or whatever and I'll be honest
I kind of felt like if I get to covid-19
I'm gonna be straight like I might be a
little you know what I'm saying might be
down for a couple days but like I didn't
see myself dying yeah but I was like
well DD's a mess I don't know what would
happen with her maybe nothing I don't
know but it's not a chance yeah I I'm
not gonna lie
I woke up the other day and was like yo
it's been a year bro you still
in the covet mindset you know it's been
a year and so if Kobe lasts forever you
can't just be chilling at the crib like
you're doing and we made good money put
money inside doing the zoom thing but
I'm I'm kind of like yo E you ain't no
today driving here is the first time
I've been in the car by myself driving
long distance to do something yeah cause
I'm telling my people I'm like yo I'm
about to go do an interview they're like
ABC NBC what you doing I was like oh no
no no I ain't ready for that not there
yet
oh okay and I was like yo it's been a
year
like unbelievable but I had to say to
myself and I'm saying it to you because
you probably think E.T always no I got
caught up a whole year at covet 19. and
so the other day I asked myself e what's
happening now like yo In This Moment
what are you doing and when are you
gonna come out of this like when
are you gonna get back on the road what
are you gonna do
um
people been hitting me up hey when is
the next conference you know you're
doing a conference I was like not only
am I not doing the conference I ain't
even thought about a conference I was
like well that's I was like yo yo I'm
gonna sit down and think should we do it
in June should we do it in whatever they
like Texas wide open Georgia wide open
you can do a car yeah like I know but
I'm not trying to get nobody sick but
it's like yo eat but you just gonna wait
until it's just nobody like you what
you're gonna wait for the numbers to be
zero so I'm saying to those of you who
are
listening life happens man it does some
of y'all might have lost somebody in
your life from covet you know you might
have lost somebody not covet I have to
remind people this other stuff you know
if somebody like you got covered I'm
like they could actually have something
else too like bronchitis like you know
what I'm saying I guess a lot of other
stuff that's out here but I would just
say to you like live in the moment and
even ET had to go eat live in the moment
like what can you do now I can get in
the car and drive and come to this
beautiful Penthouse and do an interview
like you you you knock go go like go e
and then just drive in here believe it
or not just driving here was like was
activating me like yo what let's call it
like I can't do this no more so I'm
saying to you let's live in the moment
and and let's get out of the fear let's
get out of the what if no no stay in the
what if but not what if something bad
happens what if I blow up this year what
if this is the best year of my life what
if everything I've ever dreamed up and
if you start thinking about the what ifs
in a positive you'll find yourself going
in that direction but if you go like me
what if did he get sick you'll literally
find yourself for an entire year trapped
in your house because the what if did he
get sick makes me Retreat the what if
this is the best year we've ever had
that makes me go so go go be careful be
cautious be strategic but
but don't procrastinate you know what
I'm saying so that's what I would say to
those that are listening you control the
moment you control your life you control
your mindset you control your dreams
don't let covert or nothing else control
you
I want to say to the entrepreneur that
thinks it's over that like literally and
look I'm not
I'm not making this up
it is literally at the darkest moment
right when it Dawns it is literally at
the darkest moment so you don't really
even get to the next level to your
darkest moments so that's why I'm saying
stop tripping when it gets dark and you
run it you're running from your success
like that's what you're running from so
it took me 12 years to get a four-year
degree I never quit because I realize I
had look I went through two like why
would you do something for 10 years then
quit
why would you do something for 11 years
then quit so for a lot of you you if you
was going to quit you should have quit
when you put your first Grand in it
you you like you're like 20 000 deep now
you're like 10 uh uh nine thousand eight
hundred hours deep into it it only take
ten thousand hours so it's not what
Marcus is saying is critical it is not
the darkest moment that's the problem
you the problem and your perspective is
the problem you thought you was just
gonna have a dream and a goal and you
were just gonna wake up and just walk
into the sunset you're like dream boom
it don't work like that you have a dream
and then life life punks you life punks
you and say do you really want this
I'm gonna give your wife Ms do you
really want this five of your aunts
gonna die cancer do you really want this
You're Gonna Lose Friends do you really
want this your mama gonna be pissed when
you write the book about your family do
you really want this
do you really want this cousins gonna
abandon you people that you used to be
like this with gonna think you booze you
don't want to deal with you
that's it's a part of it but I paid I
paid much if I was gonna quit I would
have quit an abandoned building when I
wanted to commit suicide and take my
life and I don't talk about that because
I don't want to give nobody ideas I
should have quit when when I heard my
voice say your mama don't want you your
own daddy don't want you take your life
I got through that so while I'm gonna
quit over a grade A F on a grade why
would I quit because I didn't do well on
the Master's Degree come on and so I'm
telling y'all you have come too far to
quit now you have invested too much to
quit now you have lost too much to quit
now get a get a reward for your pain
don't cry about it don't whine about it
get a reward for it and guess what
people Rock With Me because I know what
you've been through and I didn't quit I
know what you've been through and I
didn't stop I know what you've been
through and I didn't whine you know what
I did I got my reward for it and now did
I get a reward for it my wife got a
reward for it my kids got a reward for
it they're gonna live a different life
because of what I went through and had I
quit I would have been just like my
father who left me with nothing I'd have
been just like my grandfather who quit
so I've been in circles and in families
and environments where people take ales
I don't take ales no more no more L's in
my life I all we do is win win no man
come on stand with me all we do is win
come on all we do is come on all we do
is no matter come on all we do is come
on all we do is all we do is no matter
what so take quit not your vocabulary
take it out
cry if you must
rest if you must
rest and it's a lie you're not alone
it's a whole bunch of us here it's a
whole bunch of entrepreneurs here you
don't you ever lie and say you alone you
choose to go in the corner and cry you
choose to go in the corner and close the
door you choose to be alone we are here
and we're here for you so one more time
all we do is all we do is come on New
York all we do is no matter no matter no
matter all we do is all we do is all we
do is no matter
take losing out your vocabulary guys get
to the end and get your prize a guy
asked me about two months ago he said
E.T if there's one mistake you've made
what's that one mistake you made I just
want to be honest with you my values are
not in alignment with my dreams
he said ET what do you mean by that I
said I want to tell you a story I got a
good friend of mine who you know a good
friend of mine he came to me said Eric
my marriage is not where my marriage
needs to be I need to make some
adjustments I see you and your wife I
see how much time you spend with your
wife how much time you spend with your
children and I just I want that
you buy your wife roses regularly you're
always taking her out to eat like eat
I'm watching you you'd spoil her eat tea
but I just what can I do and so I told
him what to do and guess what he started
doing God he started doing the exact
same thing I started doing
he said Eric it's not working
like I'm doing exactly what you're doing
but it's not working I said he said why
isn't it working I said you know why
it's not working
because your values and your dreams you
say you say you want a better marriage
but I told you you need to iron your
wife's clothes you know what he told me
after a while so I'm gonna be honest
with you I know you told me to iron you
told me to wash he told me to cook but
where I come from someone be honest air
when I do that I feel like a punk and I
said that's why you're having a hard
time doing it because your value system
says a man is not supposed to iron a man
is not supposed to cook a man is not
supposed to wash dishes that's what your
value system said so you're doing one
thing but you're going against your own
value system the reason why I'm having
such an easy time washing clothes and
cooking and ironing you know why because
nothing is as important to me as my
marriage and I would rather be happy I
would rather be happy than to say I
ain't no punk let make me a punk I want
to be a punk
a happy Punk
for real no a friend of mine he came to
my house and I didn't have a mop and so
I was on the ground and I was mopping
the floor with a towel and he says E.T
the hip-hop free you're on the ground
and you're mopping I said yeah he says
your wife got you whipped I said you
didn't know
you just found that out
I've been doing a terrible job I'm sorry
I am whipped and after 23 years you
should be and if you're not it's a
problem
so listen to me there are those of you
saying I want to be a millionaire I want
to be the best at this company right but
your value system says you believe in
sleep more than you believe in grinding
your value system says you were a
consumer and not a producer
that you're spending more money than
you're making why because you are
concerned with your you're reading all
the books and you're saying everything
the books are saying but those books are
not in alignment with your values if
you're going to go to the next level
your values are going to have to change
you want you know what's so funny we
want people to make guarantees to us but
we're not willing to make guarantees to
ourselves
now for I'm gonna say it again like you
somebody gave you a guarantee 30 30 day
guarantee in 30 days if that if you
don't make what they told you was gonna
make in 30 days you got an attitude you
want your money back but you never
demanded your money back from yourself
you've never looked at yourself in the
mirror and said you let you down until
you get to that point you let you down
you've never you're not brave enough you
want to put it on somebody else the
reason why I'm not successful is because
of my boss have you ever looked at
yourself in the mirror and said I'm not
getting up on time I'm not going to work
on time I'm not putting in 120 when I'm
at work I let me down and when you get
to the point where you can say you let
you down I don't can't listen to me no
disrespect I don't care about Glenn
that's not why I do what I do and I love
Glenn I don't come here and do what I do
so Glenn can affirm me so he can give me
a pat on my back I care more about me
than I care about what Glenn thinks
about me I have standards I have values
I don't care how much you pay me if I
speak at an elementary school for 300 I
chose to do that for 300 if I chose to
speak at a prison for free I chose to do
that and I will not go in there giving
those prisoners less than when somebody
pays me a hundred thousand why because I
value myself enough to give 100 120 or
don't do it and that's the problem with
some of you you always want to blame
other people you always want to you want
to hold other people to the fire but
you're not holding yourself to the fire
you just said you're giving 50 you owe
you an explanation you owe you an
explanation you need to look at yourself
in the mirror and say why are you only
giving 50 what's wrong with you
you need to put yourself on punishment
you need to tell you no more TV no more
snacks no more desserts no more no we
working out now no no more alcohol not
right now not no I can't handle it right
now you need to tell you that you owe
you something stop going back to you you
keep going to the mall with the receipt
this is what y'all said it was Glenn you
didn't do what you said you was going to
do well you didn't do what you were
supposed to do so how am I going to do
what I'm supposed to do for you you walk
out of this room you owe yourself I
didn't get here making excuses so what
my father was in my life the truth of
the matter is he ain't never coming to
my life so what I'm gonna wait for the
rest of my life for my man to come he
ain't coming I live in America I'm an
African-American male they don't treat
us the same it's something called racism
I ain't gonna cry about it it's probably
going to be racism to the day I die but
I'm not gonna cry about it I'm still
gonna be a millionaire I'm still gonna
be one of the top motivational speakers
in the world
no I didn't grow up on that side of the
town no my mama don't have no network no
I don't know a whole lot of people no
I'm not at a country club no I don't
play golf and I don't plan on playing no
time soon but I'm still going to be
successful I'm still gonna get you where
they are why cause I owe it to myself
and can't nobody stop me but me
and you need to get rid of them excuses
you need to stop pointing fingers at
people and you start pointing fingers at
yourself what did you not do if you
can't dangle something in front of my
face that's I don't want that and many
of you are taking anything because you
don't know what you want and so if I can
do one thing for you when you leave this
room I don't want nothing from you but
for you to leave this room and know what
you want what do you want in your
marriage what do you want with your son
and your daughter what do you want in
your health what do you want financially
like how much money do you want to make
a year what do you want to drive how do
you want to live stop just waking up
like an accident what do you want and
then once you find out what you want
spend the rest of your natural life
waking up and going after it the reason
why I speak with so much passion E.T why
do you speak with so so much Authority
because I'm talking about my life not
something that I read I ate out of trash
cans
I had no business eating out of trash
cans I lived in abandoned buildings I
had no business living in abandoned
buildings
but E.T your daddy wasn't in your life
your mom was a teenage mother you you
grew up come on eat look at your search
that's not an excuse there's no excuse
for not living up to your fullest
potential no excuse they like they you
entertainment seeking
eat it you see Power absolutely not
did you see the Game of Thrones
absolutely not I'm trying to blow up
I'm trying to blow up after the blow up
I'm number one now I'm trying to find
out what's after number one and you know
what that is that's not a speaker that's
a businessman
so I'm trying to own as many companies
as I can get as much Equity as I
possibly can I got time for the Game of
Thrones I'm playing my own games
[Applause]
I'm trying to sit on the throne you know
what I'm saying trying to get a throw
I'm just saying for real some of you
broke and you still entertain
they've been tripping on those of you
who got money and you comfortable and
you want to chill and watch it I'm
talking about those of you who are
complaining about your job you ain't got
no money and you sitting here
complaining about but then you watching
all the TV programs
that's a have-not mentality
the rich person made Game of Thrones
they don't even watch it like you watch
it they can't even enjoy it they put
that joker together they watching it
like that didn't come right oh Lord she
didn't say it right they were awful oh
man okay next episode
you sitting there in a house that you
not even you can't even afford
you and your mama basement watching Game
of Thrones you just comfortable you just
I just need to come out right now see
give me a device on the next one we can
just start hitting folks in the face
just block
I need to bring you to your senses you
and your mama basement watching TV
all right all right pleasure before
payment
for real you like to get you you you do
things that you can't afford
for real you do stuff you can't afford
and then you don't understand that this
Society is built rich off of people who
like pleasure before payment
they making money off of you because you
buy a car you can't afford and they
charge you five six times more for it
they give you a house that you can't
afford and you thought it was three
hundred thousand but come to find out
when you finish paying for it 15 30
years later that house wasn't 50 100 now
it's about seven hundred thousand you
didn't pay the extra five hundred
thousand dollars for a house that's not
worth it
but they caught you because you was
broke you live in America I don't care
how bad you think it is
you have opportunities that you do not
if you get up at three o'clock in the
morning and grind in Haiti you grind
from three in the morning three in the
afternoon you still can't you can't
necessarily be a multi-millionaire some
places in Mexico you still can't wake up
and grind and still be a millionaire or
make good money you can't do it the
opportunity is not there this is an
opportunity of a lifetime so I told the
kids you got 45 African-American males
sitting in a room I said do you
understand that if you were in the same
building in this same seat 200 years ago
what would have been a difference
somebody talked to me what was what
would have been the difference same
young man who were fighting for a chance
to go to the NBA 200 years ago in that
same seat what would have been the
difference
oh it would have been 45
African-American men sitting there it
would have been
but what would have been the difference
you understand that so I told him y'all
got to understand you get to go to the
NBA your ancestors 200 years ago was big
they was about to go work in the field
somewhere so it's the same thing they
was getting drafted it was exact same
thing they looking at my man how tall
you been what can you do all right but
go work in the fields I said 200 years
later you know your Martin Luther King
would have murdered me as a speaker he
was just born at the wrong time
he's born at the wrong time you think if
Martin Luther King was alive right now
I'm just looking at his robe right he
would have had a switch sign on this
road or a jump man he would have had a
sponsor he wouldn't have been that sweet
without a sponsor every time he drank
some water it had been Gatorade or
something he would have had spot he'd
had his own shoe
but unfortunately Dr Martin Luther King
was alive in 1960 something when he was
trying to fight for our rights and so he
was murdered
imagine me get that would be crazy
somebody murdered me eating hip-hop
preaching for speaking I live in a
different time so we live in a Time guys
where we can make money
so we need to be doing what
they get money we don't live in a time
when we got a different bathroom we go
to the same bathroom I can sit in first
class now yeah look I was in first class
the other day and a lady I sat down it
was a older like old older white female
and she was just like uh I can't sit
here and it was like you can't sit there
what's wrong his cologne
I don't even work alone I was like I
only work alone right but I felt her I
ain't mad at her she grew up a long long
time ago so she like she don't want to
sit next to me
if she would have did that same thing to
me in 1960 what would have happened
I would have had to move in 2019 baby
my man was like yo
you but you're gonna have to go back
there and we're going to let somebody
back there take your seats listen to
what I'm saying we're not talking about
this country we're talking about the
fact that the opportunities are for
everybody and we're sitting here talking
about
um this ain't right this ain't right
this ain't right that ain't right some
of the stuff that we could say ain't
right ain't right but what am I doing
I'm waking up every day and doing what
I'm waking up every day and going after
what money opportunities
that's what I'm focusing on my wife
ended up getting MS
I didn't want her to work no more
because we realized the stress that was
killing her so because I'm making money
she can my kids went to college for free
they don't even know what a FAFSA is
I could be sitting here talking about
all the struggles and the worries and
whatever I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna
get out here and get these opportunities
and make this money just find somewhere
to serve and serve or if you can't find
nowhere to serve sit your butt down and
observe
sit down and observe observe where you
can serve
right so don't do all that talking don't
be running your mouth just sit down
somewhere they know you there they
invited you
so sit down and go okay where can I
serve so I was like all right Tony I got
you and I knew what he said can I be
real it stung a little bit
it did it stung a little bit you know
what I'm saying but but I was encouraged
because I knew what to do the next time
and so the next time I was with the big
boys I act like I belong there what do
they call me what what they call me on
the Block what do kids call me
now what's the name they used when they
refer to me
hip-hop preacher they never call me
doctor hip-hop preacher do they
PhD
and not like a made-up when for Michigan
State University like for real for real
I did my own dissertation for real for
real I don't walk around with Dr why
because I got this
[Applause]
man I try to keep you humble I walk
around I don't even want people to know
who I am why because I still want to
have that dog I still need to stay
hungry and when you got Pride it gets in
the way of you being hungry and you need
that hunger that's why I talk about
slavery not because I want to be
reminded of it but I remember how hungry
they were trying to be free I remember
they used to get caught I remember they
used to get lists I remember they used
to go to prison I remember the dogs used
to attack what they was fighting for
something they freedom and I'm still
fighting for something it only takes one
good idea right to become a
multi-millionaire to become a
billionaire all right yeah you feel me
one idea here's a challenge though ah
some of y'all have like six or seven of
them a week and you don't write them
down
I'm just being real like and here's what
this is what hurts me some of y'all you
look at the left and you look to the
right to be successful when you need to
look Within
like for real you were born with a gift
you were born great guys and you got to
start looking within not without listen
to me very closely a lot of you could be
millionaires
but because you're not disciplined he
pulls on a couple some of you you
because you you're not sexually
disciplined you've had people take stuff
from you and you've been in places and
relate I just saw two young women that
lost their lives that was on some dating
thing and went to some man I was like yo
where they do that at
what do you just trust somebody online
that you don't even know
foreign
house you don't even know
come on then another young lady just
went to jail her man told her to he
killed somebody and she took a saw and
saw I'm like about to go to jail is with
I'm like wow is it that love that deep
these days
people buying stuff I'm like well you
ain't grateful for what God you gotta
get the extra hookups
I ain't mad at you but if you if you do
that you understand what you attract
then and then you mad when you ain't
attracting a a successful man of
character and integrity and God but
you're not putting that out
okay I'm sorry all right
listen to me very closely somebody your
zero is gonna go to the next level when
you can learn to say no
I was just out of function my man was
like e you did a phenomenal job bro uh
we doing happy hour at 3 30. I said my
plane leave at 3 50.
he said you're not gonna stay for happy
I said bro I'm not here for no hat I
don't we don't know each other like that
happy hour I came to speak
I didn't come to build no relationship
with you
I didn't come to drink with you
drink bro I don't even drink and if I
drink I would drink at home I wouldn't
drink in front of you and get loose like
that and start talking crazy
you don't need to know me like that you
need to know me as the number one
motivational speaker in the world
flawless
I'm not but that's what you need to know
me as you don't even need to get close
enough to me to know my faults
this is a business transaction
you you're going doing business with
people drinking like y'all what you
being social for you don't have no
discipline drink when you get home you
just see some free wine
you see some free alcohol drink when you
get home this is business boundaries
there are boundaries my man like yo why
you gotta go cause I'm married I got a
wife I'm going home we finished
we ain't got no more business to do you
told me you wanted to our presentation I
did it I'm going home but e this is a
resort and
I'm going home why because I can't get
in trouble at home
I can't get in trouble at the crib I can
get in trouble at this Resort
[Applause]
it's a lot of Temptation at this Resort
so I'm going home worked on my gift I
realized that all of us are born with a
gift but you gotta hone it you know it's
just not you're not going to become
great and we talk about the school of
greatness you know we talk about
um you know greatness is upon you and I
realize that my gift wasn't going to
create itself my gift wasn't going to
nurture itself my gift wasn't going to
perfect itself that was something I had
to do and so man before you know it we
did a video that went viral I think it's
got over 50 million hits now and we turn
our passion into a profit turtle man
yeah I love it turn our passion into
problems I was working on my second book
my other book just came out today for
the school system I was working on the
next one
yo yo your fiancee said what because she
helped me with the book she said what
she said what to you about me doing the
second book
[Music]
we were 95 done with the first book I'm
like let's go with the second book it's
let's go
let's go they're like we ain't finished
the first one I said we gotta eat
we gotta eat y'all I'm number one in the
world how long you think that's gonna
last you think that's gonna last for 20
years you think it ain't no kid out
there watching me who gonna be better
than me in the next year or two you
think I'm gonna be number one forever so
why I'm number one let's eat why I'm
number one let's get every gig we can
get well I'm number one let's do
corporate let's do NBA let's do NFL
let's do Major League Baseball let's do
soccer I got clients and everyone we
gonna eat
and y'all do that little stuff about you
gonna eat but y'all ain't got no doggo
motor you get tired quick
did you practice for one or two days you
go out you do a couple hours you tired
but yeah you competing against people
right now that's their lifestyle and you
think they about to let you take their
lifestyle
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Alex hermosi
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there most small
entrepreneurs try and get customers to
make sales bigger entrepreneurs try to
make sales to get customers and the
difference is one person is all about
trying to get the money as fast as
possible what do I need to say to get
this person say yes